[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala Ya está lista con
nosotros en el estudio para hablar mar
de la viruela del mono feliz mañana de
lunes Qué está pasando con esta
emergencia sanitaria cómo está Raúl esta
emergencia de la viruela del mono que
tanto Tratamos de hace unos meses y que
parece que esté desapareciendo ahora de
los titulares todavía no ha terminado
sigue siendo considerada una emergencia
por la Organización Mundial de la Salud
pero si está en declive en los países
digamos del Norte global que muchas
veces son los que ponen sobre la mesa
por ejemplo pues la agenda mediática o
la que se considera una crisis o no
vamos a revisar las cifras la
información epidemiológica de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud vemos
aquí como los casos empezaron a aumentar
en mayo a partir de junio la franja roja
es de Europa la franja azul es América
vemos por ejemplo como a partir de
agosto más o menos empezó a caer los
casos en Europa y con un poquito más de
retraso el continente americano también
está en bajada ahora sin embargo estas
cifras ocultan algunas otras verdades y
matices Como por ejemplo que sobre todo
en Estados Unidos donde están cayendo
los casos un declive del 85% de los
momentos más álgidos sin embargo en
otros países como Colombia Perú Brasil
que también están afectados por esta
crisis ahora mismo no está claro que la
tendencia todavía sea a la baja a qué se
atribuye que en Europa y en Estados
Unidos estén cayendo los casos Pues
bueno primero porque el virus estaba
circulando en una población
relativamente restringida como decíamos
mayoritariamente aunque no
exclusivamente hombres gays o bisexuales
que además tenían por ejemplo más de una
pareja sexual a lo largo de un tiempo
relativamente corto no en ese caso pues
son un grupo pequeño de personas que una
parte ya se ha quedado inmunizada
también pues las campañas de vacunación
que con algunos tropiezos en estos
países del Norte global digamos han
logrado proteger a una parte de la
población y pues los cambios de
comportamiento no las campañas de
prevención enfocadas particularmente a
toda la población pero también a esta
comunidad una además pues muy organizada
con muchas lecciones aprendidas por
ejemplo del VIH que rápidamente ha
sabido Cómo adaptarse a este nuevo
riesgo bueno mar ahora qué ha pasado
digamos lo peor del oleada en estas
regiones que estamos hablando que
sabemos de cómo se ha comportado el
virus no en toda su trayectoria Claro ya
podemos empezar a hacer una mirada
retrospectiva y la verdad es que todavía
no se sabe tanto O al menos no sabe
tanto que sea útil digamos para predecir
que puede pasar en el futuro estamos
todavía un poco a ciegas Pero hay un
estudio por ejemplo muy interesante
publicado por los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades en Estados
Unidos que estudiaron a 57 pacientes
hospitalizados por birola del mono qué
vieron que el 82% eran asero positivos
del virus de la inmunodeficiencia humana
más de dos tercios eran afroamericanos y
casi un cuarto eran a personas que
vivían en la calle que no tenían casa En
ese momento no De hecho los cdc decían
eso que la viruela del mono y el VIH
habían chocado con efectos trágicos y
además como vemos totalmente atravesadas
por problemas de desigualdad y lo mismo
pasa con las vacunas por ejemplo no de
todas las dosis administradas de la
vacuna de la viruela usada contra la
viruela del mono en Estados Unidos solo
el 9% fue por ejemplo a personas
afroamericanas no una cambio una
proporción totalmente pues fuera de lo
que debería hacer y especialmente cuando
vemos que las personas hospitalizadas
eran afroamericanas Y es que en realidad
pues eso como decíamos las campañas de
vacunación han sido desplegadas con
muchísimas dificultades y esto en un
país como Estados Unidos donde sí Hay
acceso a la vacuna no poco poco hablamos
de la región latinoamericana donde la up
se prometió vacunas pero todavía no han
llegado a la población o el continente
africano donde ni siquiera se plantea
esa posibilidad ahora mismo precisamente
mar cuál es esa situación actual del
continente africano no hablando de la
viruela al mono claro son los es la
región donde hay los países endémicos de
esta enfermedad y por eso En verdad es
la primera línea de frente para contener
posibles futuros brotes en el 202 según
la información de los cdc de África se
han registrado casi 7.000 escasos 173 o
muertes Eso significa una tasa de
mortalidad del 2,5% muchísimo más alta
de lo que se está registrando en países
como europeos o Estados Unidos no
actualmente hay casos en 8 países
endémicos son los que ven en este mapa
marcados en rojo mencionamos
especialmente República democrática del
Congo que acumula casi 4.000 casos y
también Nigeria que actualmente está
empezando a vivir un brote y luego cinco
países no endémicos verdaderamente con
muy poquitos casos como Marruecos Egipto
Sudán entre otros no es destacable
además que la inmensa mayoría de los
casos son sospechosos No No confirmados
Y eso nos habla uno Pues de que la
dimensión del brote puede estar muy
subestimada y dos esa de esa falta de
acceso por ejemplo incluso a los kits de
diagnóstico de viruela del mono en el
Continente mar como está combatiendo el
continente estos brotes Pues con las
uñas y dientes con muy poco acceso
tratamientos muy poco acceso a
protocolos una unos periodistas de
routers viajaron a República democrática
del Congo precisamente para contestar
esta pregunta y escuchemos una de las
respuestas que obtuvieron sí
Europa con solo algunos casos de
enfermedad menos muertos y una tasa de
infección más lenta pudo acceder a la
vacuna porque no en r.c
nuestra preocupación es que si hay una
vacuna Debería ser para nosotros sí sí
hay un tratamiento un protocolo
deberíamos recibirlo porque estamos en
la línea de frente somos los primeros en
intervenir incluso
no se la pueden quedar en Europa
claro Raúl y no solo no hay vacunas
Porque estos países no están teniendo
por ejemplo el dinero de comprarla a la
farmacéutica sino tampoco como decíamos
no hay test no hay tratamientos
antivirales la Organización Mundial de
la Salud ha intentado distribuir por
ejemplo al menos los kits de diagnóstico
pero no ha supuesto una gran cambio por
las para las personas y recordemos eso
que la enfermedad no es una enfermedad
nueva y Lleva años décadas afectando el
continente y nunca Ni siquiera se había
planteado usar la vacuna para de la
viruela para combatir la viruela del
mono en estos países no esperemos que al
menos ahora con la alarma internacional
que se ha despertado a raíz de que la
enfermedad llegara a otros lugares pues
haya un poco más de atención un poco más
de recursos y de investigación al
respecto Ojalá así sea mar como siempre
un gusto hablar con usted de temas de
salud mañana con más mañana más